l'ex bonne foi de l'inde sortir et la
ps4 pendant seulement quelques jours vie
sociale où es-tu et social oui du vie
sociale j'ai acheté l'ex médecin le jour
de sa sortie autant dire que sur le
chemin du magasin de jeux vidéo jusqu'à
chez moi j'étais un peu tendu alors dans
la rue j'avais l'air de quelqu'un de
tout à fait normal qui vient d'acheter
un truc un magasin un peu plus banal
mais par contre dans ma tête j'avais
l'impression que tous les gens qui me
regardent et vous voyez ça
du coup j'ai développé deux techniques
pour échapper aux voleurs et aux
raquetteurs à savoir premièrement la
technique du bora et deuxièmement une
petite technique secrète que les
développer la technique du camouflage
indétectable enfin quand tu rentres chez
toi viens le moment le plus orgasmique
de taissy dernières années le boxing
oh
exceptionnellement cette année pour moi
c'était le moment le plus orgasmique de
toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
les deux d'un coup un petit plaisir un
gros un gros plaisir
en revanche avec la xbox j'ai une énorme
déception je m'attendais à ce que ça se
passe comme ça à il boxe salon quoi bien
mais vous monsieur marc écoutes ça va ça
va à la routine autunois stanka hristova
j'ai envie de jouer là de suite monsieur
est est ce que tu vas me faire un petit
café aussi un long puisque j'ai besoin
d'énergie là je suis extrêmement métier
je vous prépare ça votre café est prêt à
fait merci en fait base s'est toujours
passé comme ça j'ai finalement xbox lens
rise lens
rise s'il te plaît
lens rise jean michel edouard finissait
alors sa journée en position foetale
dans un coin de sa chambre
c'est marrant parce qu'avant qu'elles
sortent ces consoles on a pu voir dans
les commentaires de vidéos youtube ou
même à la télé ou un peu partout de gros
débats concernant laquelle des deux
consoles est la meilleure du coup on a
vu deux équipes surgir ceux qui
défendent l aps cat et ceux qui
défendent et la xbox roanne alors c'est
marrant parce qu'un pro x box one est un
pro ps4 comme les débats étaient
ensemble ils avaient l'impression qu'ils
étaient dans un combat super stylé que
c'est un petit peu comme ça ok ayant
seniors elle leur routeur pierre dionne
labelle votre one et canon sur bsk te
lèves devient payant et pour le prier
faut vraiment être un conte
ok et lyon et donc attendre c'est
complètement débile ce que tu viens de
dire sur xbox 360 qui l'avait déjà
payant depuis sais pas combien d'années
et le encore sur xbox one ah ok et yo yo
après ce cas c'est la meilleure des
façons la connecter à internet toutes
les 24 heures du coup quand tu pars en
vacances tu l'as dans le
[Applaudissements]
ok ok helio et lioret attentes en
chutant à tout de suite mais ce que tu
veux dire c'est complètement débile qui
part en vacances avec sa console eu bat
xbox et jamais le même appel outre aux
alors qu'en réalité d'un point de vue
extérieur on avait juste l'impression de
voir ça en fait
l'iphone os 4 et 9 fois chacun fait ce
qu a fait mieux encore soigné bien il y
avait toujours dans ce fameux débat à un
mec qui sortait de nulle part et qui
arrivait pour dire excusez moi à le pc
le plus puissant les graphismes son
meilleur hockey
ils bloquent tout allait mieux un bon
n'ont rien on peut tester la puissance
du pc semaine j'ai l'impression que
c'est un petit peu le leapster du débat
en fait personne ne faisait attention le
message qui va suivre est extrêmement
important aucune de ces deux consoles
les meilleurs culotta un peu le choix va
juste dépendre des exclusivités qui vous
intéresse le plus est de vous pousser
mon interface à trouver la personne etc
même si pour moi la meilleure des deux
reste là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]